لطالما كانت السماء سحرًا حيث
كانت مملكة الآلهة
والحضارات تتجه نحوها
لقرون ،
لكن مكشطة السماء هي فكرة حديثة تمامًا
أصبحت ممكنة بفضل التقنيات الحديثة
ناطحات السحاب هي حقًا
اختراع أمريكي كان أول
استخدام للكلمة حوله  في ثمانينيات القرن التاسع عشر
كانت مباني مكاتب
ركزت
على قوة عاملة واستخدمت تقنيات
مثل المصعد
مثل البناء الفولاذي للبناء بكفاءة
عالية وتكديس الكثير من المساحة على قطعة صغيرة
من الأرض
باستخدام إطارات فولاذية للدعم الهيكلي
بدلاً من جدران البناء الثقيلة التي
كان المهندسون المعماريون قادرين عليها  للحصول على
ناطحات سحاب إبداعية بدأت في الارتفاع
مع مطلع القرن العشرين ،
كانت هناك
منافسة لتكون أعلى
[موسيقى] في
العالم وأصبح برج القمة هذا
مرتبطًا بشكل وثيق مع
أعمدة ربط ناطحات السحاب الحديثة لطائرات الغد العظيمة
[الموسيقى]
بعد العالم  الحرب الثانية نوع جديد من
تكنولوجيا الزجاج
يسمح بنوافذ الحائط الساتر
يمكن أن تفتح الطريق أمام الجدران الزجاجية العملاقة
التي أعطت مساحة أرضية أكبر وضوءًا طبيعيًا
ولكن تم إغلاق الهواء النقي
واستبداله بتكييف الهواء في
الستينيات والسبعينيات من القرن الماضي والتي كانت فترة
مركز التجارة العالمي مع
البرجين التوأمين برج سيرز في شيكاغو
أصبحت أطول قليلاً
ولكنها كانت أيضًا نهاية حقبة حيث
بدأت المدن الأمريكية في التواجد في الضواحي
وانتشارها ، وقد قادنا الشحنة إلى
السماء ولكن
سرعان ما وقع بقية العالم في هونغ كونغ
حيث الأرض نادرة جدًا  إن الارتفاع هو
الحل الوحيد تقريبًا
هو تلك الحاجة من حيث التوسع الحضري ، لذلك
يحتاج الناس إلى نقل المدن التي يحتاجون
إليها
للعمل للعيش في
آسيا والشرق الأوسط ، لقد أخذناها إلى
مستوى آخر
كل مدينة تريد أن يكون لديها هذا المعلم
الذي يعطي
ذلك  حس الثقافة المتميزة من
نهاية القرن العشرين ، قام
المهندسون المعماريون في الشرق
بتطوير تقنيات جديدة للتغلب على
الريح والتسلق إلى أعلى ،
فأنت تريد تصميم شكل غير
مربع
تريده  الزوايا المظلمة أو الزوايا ذات الأوجه
بحيث تزيل الضغط
عن المبنى عندما تضربه الرياح ،
تقوم بتصميم المبنى لأقسم
قليلاً ،
نستخدم الخرسانة المسلحة للحصول على تلك
المرونة التي
تمتص الحركة أيضًا
، استخدم تايبيه 101 تصميمًا متدرجًا
قطع الزوايا و  جهاز ترطيب معلق 700 طن
للمساعدة في ضرب
الأعاصير والزلازل ،
لكن دبي برج خليفة
أعاد تعريف الأداة الفائقة
وقدرتها على شكل مدبب مبالغ فيه على
الثني حتى ستة أقدام في الجزء العلوي
وجلد خارجي مزدوج الطبقات
يساعده على مواجهة العواصف الصحراوية و
الحرارة
الشديدة لبناء أطول برج في العالم هي
عرض رائع
للمعرفة التكنولوجية بالإضافة إلى ثروة بالطبع ،
لكن طليعة المهندسين المعماريين
ركزت بشدة على الاستدامة ،
فنحن نريد تصميم شيء
مستدام قدر الإمكان
من حيث المساحات  استخدام
مواد
المباني الشاهقة مستدام حيث
يمكن أن يكون لدينا الكثير من الأشخاص
في مساحة صغيرة لكننا جميعًا
نفهم ذلك
البناء في حد ذاته يأخذ الموارد
من الأرض
في مدن مثل هونغ كونغ حيث
تهيمن ناطحات السحاب على البيئة
ولكنها تساهم أيضًا بشكل كبير في
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري ، حيث
أصبح الوصول إلى السماء منذ قرون
الآن موضع شك ، حيث
أصبحت ناطحات السحاب مفاوضات معقدة
بين الطريقة التي نريد أن نعيش بها
في المستقبل وإمكانيات كيف
يمكننا أن
يكون هناك العديد من الأساليب المختلفة
لثقافة حكومة السياسة العامة
التي تقيد أو تمكن
ناطحات السحاب